[Music]
kevin is in richmond virginia hi kevin
how are you
hi doing well how are you doing
gentlemen better than i deserve how can
we help
all right so i've been a dave ramsey
listener for probably a year going on
two years now
and after me and my wife's
second wedding this year thanks to kovit
we ended up sitting down talking about
our finances we were fresh out of
college
all kinds of fun you know college loan
debt
bought a house
both have vehicles on loans
and i just want to get a glass of the
baby steps you know we got through the
first one
of the book got through the first one
was motivated and we just cannot seem to
get
baby step two so i was wondering what
advice you can give somebody that's
struggling to stay on the grind of
getting past step two since that's
probably one of the hardest ones
so when you say you're struggling with
this is it are you not seeing progress
or are you just not doing it
i would say a little bit of both um i'd
put the blame on myself saying that i'm
the one that's kind of the
the rational spender
when i see a good deal i go after it and
that's my fault
um but you know i recognize it and i
want to do better by but
that's really the big struggle for me is
that when i get a little bit of debt i
see room and i try to fill it right back
up when i find a good deal
yeah my dad used to tell me when i was a
kid he'd say go clean the garage and i
said are you going to help he said no i
thought of it
he said recognizing the problem is 90 of
solving it
yeah
and i've already went through and kind
of sold everything
that i didn't need everything that had a
value um within me and my wife's house
just to you know try to get some
motivation some extra room to start it
get the ball rolling yeah but then you
went out and spent everything at target
it did yes so that didn't do any good
you just spinning your wheels
so uh how old are you guys
uh i'm 24 my wife's 23. cool so what's
your household income
household income
i would say is around 90 000. good for
you what do you do for a living
uh you'll laugh at this one i'm a
finance director cool no it's not
unusual at all man i had a finance
degree and couldn't add up my own budget
they don't teach us
hey they don't teach us that they teach
us corporate finance when we're getting
our degrees
they don't teach you anything about
personal finance so it's not unusual
and what's your wife do
my wife's a teacher good okay
and um how much debt do you have not
counting the house you bought
not counting the house
it's probably
around
i'd say a hundred thousand
what's that on
uh so student loans for me is 75 000 for
my wife is 36 000 she got extremely uh
lucky and blessed and had some of her
stuff forgiven
uh and then i have a truck at 25 000
and my wife has a car at 7 000 and then
all the credit card debt is me
at about 4 500.
okay i thought you said a hundred
thousand
uh what i'm sorry what did that add
yeah it ended up being a little more
than 100 150 yeah
yeah
okay
all right so here
um
in order to do your day job
you have to be more detailed than you've
been
on this subject
you have the intellectual capability to
be detailed
and to lay out a process and follow a
process
you have emotionally chosen not to do
that so far
an indication of that is i have a
hundred thousand dollars worth of debt
when actually you have about 150.
okay
yeah you following me
so yeah what you're going to have to do
is rise up out of
the uh a little bit of hopelessness
and a little bit of immaturity
that you've described and say time for
me and my new wife
to be adults throw our shoulders back
because children do what feels good
adults devise a plan and follow it
and i want you to pretend like i just
hired you for two hundred thousand
dollars a year to fix this simple little
mess you have
because
in terms of mathematics it's a very
simple primitive mess
there's not that much to it the only
problem with it is the person in your
mirror
make sense
oh yeah i agree with you this is all
behavior it's not intellect you don't
have an intellectual problem you're very
smart
there's no question about that yeah
kevin have you guys been through
financial peace university
uh we have not no well what i want to do
is gift you guys ramsey plus and that's
the membership that will give you access
to financial peace university every
dollar our budgeting tool the premium
version and what i want you to do is
make a budget if you're not already it
sounds like you're probably not doing a
regular budget uh and then go through
financial peace university with your
wife sit down watch all nine lessons and
you gotta get intense man because right
now i think we care more than you do
about getting out of debt
and you got to care you've got to say i
want a different future for me
i gotta i gotta poke at you enough to
piss you off
honey dee i need to get you mad in a
good way you know what i'm talking about
like like like i'm the drill sergeant
and you're in boot camp
yeah that's for the uh and so george is
putting you in boot camp can you treat
it that way if we give it to you as a
free gift
i think i could intellectually decide
i'm in boot camp i'm gonna get my butt
kicked here and i'm gonna do everything
exactly as these people say i'm not
gonna second-guess anything because i'm
the guy who made a mess not the guy who
cleaned it up but you're about to be the
guy that cleaned it up if you'll follow
this exactly what we tell you to do
you're going to be out of debt in
100 debt-free in two years
other than your house
you may or may not sell the truck in
that process i'll leave that up to you
that truck's questionable but the rest
of it is just you're gonna have to get
after it and you know scratch and claw
and keep your butt out of target
that's the thing
so it's a danger zone yeah i mean you
don't you just i hey i'm just like you
man this is how i learned this stuff
when i first started this stuff i
thought that when you went to sam's or
costco the reason they checked your
receipt on the way out was i thought it
was federal law you had to spend 200
bucks when you're in there
and i thought they were checking to make
sure i spent my 200 bucks oh you didn't
you got to go back in there and get some
more peanut butter dude get that five
gallons of peanut butter because you
hadn't spent your 200 bucks because you
i just went in there and buy crap
i mean this dopamine rush that you get
of just buying stuff
and those of us that are spenders we
understand that but you've got to get up
over the top of that
and say hey if i can get my act together
if i live like no one else later i can
live and give like no one else changes
everything turns out you can go broke
saving money
how's that for a deal everything's 100
off when you don't buy it
oh man george that's right i'm excited
to be a sergeant in this boot camp i've
never been a sergeant it's exciting
there you go just work on it
i can i can just see you yelling at
somebody i've got a great yell yeah i
bet